- [Voiceover] A line is graphed
aand the X-Y plane is shown.
Which of the following
equations represents the line,
they give us a bunch of equations here.
And so there's several
ways we can tackle it.
When we look at this
I can see there's two
interesting points here,
there's the point when X
is, let me just write this,
and I should be writing a little bit lower
so we can look at it at the same time
that I look at the equation choices.
So we see that when X is to zero,
Y is one.
So that is the Y intercept, we could say.
And then you can see
when X is six, Y is zero.
When X is six, Y is zero.
So a very kind of basic
way of approaching this
is see like, oh, when X is to zero,
Y needs to be equal to one.
When X is zero, we get
six Y is equal to one.
Well then Y is going
to be equal to one six,
rule that one out.
When X is equal to zero
Y needs to be equal to one.
If X is zero, then six Y equals six.
Yeah, Y is going to be equal to one.
Now when Y is zero,
X is going to be, X
needs to be equal to six.
So if Y is zero this goes away
and X is equal to six.
So we're done.
This is our choice.
Now there's other ways that we can do it.
We could write it first
in slope intercept form
and convert to this form right over here,
so let's do it that way, as well.
So we could say that the
equation of this line
is going to be Y,
if I write it in y = mx = b form
where M is the slope
and B is the Y intercept,
we already know that B is equal to one.
so we already know that's one.
And what's the slope?
Well slope is our change in Y
for given change in X.
And we see when our change in X
is positive six,
when our change in X is positive six,
our change in Y is negative one.
So our slope is we decrease in Y by one
when we increase in X by six,
is negative one sixth.
So the equation of the line
Y is equal to negative one
sixth X, this is the slope,
plus one.
And then we could convert to
the forms that we have here.
So let's see, we could add
one sixth X to both sides,
and you're gonna get
one sixth X plus Y is equal to one.
And that's not quite what we have here,
all the X coefficients on X are just one.
So we could multiply both sides of this
times six and we would get
X plus six Y is equal to six,
which is exactly the
choice that we picked.